Lyne Morissette, biologiste
et spécialiste des mammifères
marins et du fonctionnement
des écosystèmes. Vous êtes
à Rimouski, Mme Morissette.
Merci d'être là.
- Bonjour, M. Roy.
- Alors, Journée mondiale
des océans, il y a eu
des colloques aujourd'hui,
un rapport ça d'épais de l'ONU,
en deux mots, ça va pas bien.
Qu'est-ce qui va le plus mal,
selon vous?
- Bien, c'est un bilan de santé,
c'est un deuxième bilan de
santé. On en avait fait un
en 2017. Il y a quand même
des choses qui vont bien.
Il y a les aires marines
protégées qu'on a réussi
à augmenter un peu partout
sur la planète. Il y a certains
endroits où il y a une bonne
gestion des pêcheries et
une bonne gestion des polluants,
mais sinon, vous l'avez dit,
ce qu'on voit dans le rapport,
c'est surtout des dossiers
sur lesquels ça ne s'est pas
amélioré, au contraire.
Le bruit sous-marin, ça ne s'est
pas amélioré. Tout ce qui est
surpêche, dans la majorité des
cas, ça ne s'est pas amélioré.
Sinon, la pollution par
le plastique, la perte d'habitat
et évidemment, tout ce qui est
conséquences des changements
climatiques, ce sont
des dossiers qui ne se sont pas
améliorés. Donc, un bilan
de santé assez troublant,
quatre ans plus tard,
avec ce deuxième rapport.
- Bon, ce qui est peut-être
le plus inquiétant, c'est
le réchauffement de l'eau,
parce que le plastique,
c'est épouvantable, on voit
des photos. Mais à la limite,
on peut se ressaisir, aller
l'enlever, arrêter d'en mettre,
si je veux être optimiste.
Mais le réchauffement,
quelle est la conséquence
du réchauffement de l'eau
des océans?
- Il y a un paquet de choses
qui arrivent quand l'eau
se réchauffe. Il y a des
efflorescences d'algues
toxiques, il y en a de plus
en plus. Juste au niveau
physique, l'expansion thermique
contribue, quand l'océan
se réchauffe, à l'augmentation
du niveau de la mer.
L'augmentation du niveau de
la mer, entre parenthèses,
c'est le facteur pour lequel
c'est complètement irréversible.
On ne pourra jamais baisser
le niveau d'eau. Donc, pour
la plupart des autres affaires,
si on se ressaisit, comme
vous dîtes, on peut peut-être
renverser la vapeur.
Pour l'augmentation du niveau
de la mer, c'est impossible.
Pour le réchauffement,
ça va être très difficile.
Et qu'est-ce que ça fait?
Ça fait des espèces qui perdent
leur habitat, qui vont changer
de région parce que l'eau
n'est plus à la bonne
température pour eux.
Ça fait de la pollution
supplémentaire, ça fait que
les courants changent. Le Gulf
Stream dans l'Atlantique est
30 % moins puissant qu'il
l'était depuis son histoire.
Donc, le changement de
la température de l'eau,
ça va aussi affecter toute
la machine climatique,
les événements météo extrêmes.
Donc ça, au final, c'est nous,
les humains, qui allons en subir
les conséquences.
- Je voyais des images pendant
que vous parliez, des coraux qui
blanchissent, donc des coraux
qui meurent. Et j'écoutais
un documentaire hier
et la personne disait :
si les arbres sur la planète
se mettaient à blanchir comme
les coraux, on parlerait de ça
à tous les jours aux nouvelles.
Or, on les voit moins les
coraux, mais c'est épouvantable.
Quel est le danger de la perte
des coraux?
- C'est toujours plus facile
de parler d'une coupe à blanc
que de ce qui est caché
sous la surface. Mais oui,
effectivement, le blanchiment
des coraux, c'est toute
une biodiversité, c'est
cette structure d'un écosystème
qui nous aide à freiner
les changements climatiques
parce qu'ils sont capables
de capter une partie
du carbone atmosphérique.
C'est une structure
de biodiversité dans laquelle
il y a des milliers
sinon des millions d'espèces
qui survivent et puis qui
nous servent nous, les humains,
en termes de produits et
services, en termes de tourisme
pour aller voir cette beauté-là,
en termes de découvertes
médicales. Il y a des secrets
cachés dans nos récepteurs
coralliens dans nos océans qu'on
n'a même pas encore découverts.
Donc, les protéger, ce n'est pas
seulement parce que c'est beau,
c'est crucial à notre survie.
Puis souvent, le drame,
c'est que ça se passe sous
la surface et on n'est pas
vraiment conscient de ça
parce qu'on ne le voit pas
comme si c'était une forêt.
- Parce que le blanchiment,
c'est comme vous dîtes,
c'est que le corail absorbe
plus de chaleur parce que l'eau
est plus chaude. D'ailleurs,
on va voir un graphique, l'eau
arrête pas de se réchauffer
depuis 25 ans. L'eau, vous
le voyez, la moyenne, 1971-2000,
ça monte vers le haut.
Comme vous dîtes, ce serait
étonnant que ça se renverse.
Mais donc, je disais donc que
le blanchiment, c'est la
première étape mais ça peut
aller jusqu'à la mort du corail.
- Bien oui, parce que quand...
Le blanchiment des récifs
coralliens, en fait, c'est
qu'un corail normalement,
c'est une symbiose entre
deux organismes, et puis,
c'est une plante et puis...
C'est une algue et puis
un autre organisme qui vivent
en symbiose. Et quand
le blanchiment se produit,
en fait, c'est que l'algue
quitte le corail. Et la machine
donc, c'est comme s'il manquait
une pièce dans votre moteur.
Donc, cette machine-là,
qui est le récif corallien,
ne fonctionne plus.
Puis ça fait pas seulement
une perte de couleur, mais ça
fait la perte de fonctionnement
d'un écosystème qui est
bien rodé et qui supporte
comme habitat des centaines
d'autres espèces.
Donc c'est ça qui arrive
quand on parle de blanchiment.
- Bon, les gens, quand on parle
de ça, se disent : Ah!
C'esten Australie, mais c'est
partout. Dans toutes les mers,
il y a des coraux. Plus près de
chez nous, vous êtes à Rimouski.
On regarde derrière vous,
c'est magnifique.
L'état de nos océans à nous,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire?
- Bien, le grand message ou
le constat que l'on peut faire,
c'est qu'on n'est pas isolé
ici sur... Le Saint-Laurent
n'est pas isolé sous une cloche
de verre. On a aucune raison
d'avoir la prétention de penser
qu'on est meilleur qu'ailleurs
ou que ça va mieux qu'ailleurs.
Quand on parle d'acidification
des océans, de zones mortes
où il n'y a plus assez
d'oxygène, de pollution
plastique, peu importe
l'enjeu dans ce fameux rapport
de 1200 pages qui est sorti
aujourd'hui, on pourrait refaire
le même bilan d'état de santé
pour le Saint-Laurent
et ce serait pas mal similaire.
- Donc on ne peut pas se dire
en couchant : on est meilleur,
nous Ah! On s'occupe mieux
de notre littoral ou de ce
que... On est tous interreliés?
- Ce serait réconfortant
de pouvoir faire ça, mais
malheureusement, on ne peut pas
le faire. Il n'y a pas de
"ailleurs" dans ce genre
de situation-là. On ne peut pas
se dire : Ah! C'est ailleurs,
ça se passe dans le Pacifique.
Ça se passe chez nous aussi
pour la plupart des enjeux.
Donc, non, on ne peut pas
se coucher le soir, l'esprit
tranquille, en se disant
que ce n'est pas grave.
- Et je le disais, le plastique
et ce genre de choses, il y a
un contrôle plus évident.
Pour le réchauffement de
la planète, ça nous renvoie à
cet énorme dossier qui est réel.
- Oui, puis pour
le réchauffement climatique
comme pour les autres enjeux
océaniques, je pense que
ce qui est important de faire
présentement, c'est de penser
à ce qu'on fait, de revoir
notre façon de faire.
Et si la pandémie a été utile
pour une chose, c'est peut-être
de nous présenter des modèles ùu
justement on revoit notre façon
de travailler, on fait
du télétravail, on a fait plus
d'achats locaux, on a revu
nos modes de transport parce
qu'on n'avait pas le choix.
Peut-être que ça, s'il y a
un côté positif à la pandémie,
c'est de nous avoir peut-être
appris à utiliser ce genre
de modèle. Et j'espère que c'est
ce qui va rester après-coup
dans notre façon de faire
parce qu'on peut travailler...
On peut freiner ça ou même
renverser la vapeur, mais
il va falloir travailler fort.
Et dans le rapport, ce qu'on
conclut, c'est que la seule
façon d'y arriver, c'est
en deux mots : coopération,
collaboration. Donc, il va
falloir travailler ensemble.
Et c'est seulement comme ça,
je pense, qu'on va être capable
d'avoir des résultats
significatifs.
- Il n'y a pas de magie là
non plus. Lyne Morissette,
biologiste, spécialiste
des mammifères marins et du
fonctionnement des écosystèmes,
vous nous parliez de Rimouski.
C'est magnifique derrière vous.
Il a l'air à faire chaud aussi,
on voit une espèce de
brouillard.
- Mais on a le vent.
Ça aide beaucoup.
- Bonne fin de journée!